الولايات المتحده تغرق بالمخدرات والمكسيك
في دائره الاتهام والسبب مخدر الفانتاويل
المخدر الفتاك دفع باعضاء من الحزب
الجمهوري الى اقتراح ادراج مافيات
المخدرات المكسيكيه على قوائم الارهاب او
حتى قصفها بالصواريخ
الرئيس السابق ناقش ارسل قوات خاصه
واستخدام الحرب الالكترونيه لاستهداف قاده
المافيا اذا اعيد انتخابه ليست المره
الاولى التي يتحدث فيها ترامب عن ذلك ففي
ولايته طلب من وزير الدفاع انذاك ماك عام
2020 اطلاق صواريخ على المكسيك لتدمير
مختبرات تصنيع المخدرات وفقا ما ذكره اسبر
في مذكراته لكن يبدو ان هذا التوجه يروق
اخرين ثم نواب جمهوري يؤيدون استخدام
القوه العسكريه ضد الكارتيلات المكسيكيه
وتقنيدها ايضا
لاستهداف المافيات حتى بدون اذن المكسيك
تلك اتهامات ودعوات ترفضها الاخيره
رفض وصفه السيناتور الجمهوري لينز
بحاله انكار
شركائنا في المكسيك في حاله انكار تامه
رئيس المكسيك ينكر ان بلاده ملاذ امن
لعصابات المخدرات التي تدير مناطق في
المكسيك ويقول ان الامر ليس صحيحا ويلومنا
على ازمه الفينتنايل
الرئيس المكسيكي نفى انتاج الفينت نايل في
بلاده فيما يؤكد مسؤولون امريكيون عكس ذلك
لا بل وينتج باستخدام مواد كيميائيه
مصدرها الصين
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات